deux ans au service des entrepreneurs
c'est l'objectif du réseau plato un
programme originaire de belgique
introduit en france dans les années 90
le 5 juillet le plateau paris-saclay
2014 2016 a dressé son bilan synchrotron
soleil 74 pme du territoire ont pu
profiter des conseils de coachs cadres
de grandes entreprises autour de la
table ce ne sont que des dirigeants
d'entreprises et ce qui est intéressant
pour eux c'est d'utiliser l'expérience
et de faire partager leur expérience aux
autres membres du groupe
ça leur a permis vraiment de prendre de
la hauteur par rapport à leur quotidien
et de prendre des décisions qui les ont
aidés à faire croître et leur chiffre
d'affaires en général et notamment au
niveau humain pour certains beaucoup de
dirigeants ont embauché un dispositif
mis en place en partenariat avec les
chambres de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles yvelines et de l'essonne
rompre l'isolément devenir plus
compétitifs et managez une équipe
autant de problématiques abordées durant
les réunions une fois par mois qu'on se
pose des questions qu'on ne se posait
pas ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on a
des regards qui sont pas ceux que l'on
aurait on est sensibilisé à des sujets
qu'on n'a pas appris à l'école en ce qui
me concerne j'ai une formation
scientifique j'ai pas après tous ces
sujets rh effet appris sur le terrain
c'est aussi une façon de faire partie du
thé du tissu économique local
de se rapprocher des autres entreprises
pour clore cette session les dirigeants
ont été invités à peindre un tableau
pour illustrer leur expérience à l'issue
de ce plateau paris-saclay 86% des chefs
d'entreprise prévoient de recruter dans
les deux ans coût de l'adhésion de 1500
euros pour un plateau territoriales en
france 1500 pme et pmi ont déjà investi
dans ce programme